[Music]
launch sign is a street football
tournament the unites communities and
brings down social barriers realize like
the kids here they don't believe become
too much they don't feel like it too
much
so instead of talking I said why don't I
create something I've come to an event
in the streets and you see tents you see
a DJ there's a lot of fans you don't
normally see those things and ends like
you see those things on Sky Sports I did
a snack advert you've got five minutes
to win or you score two goals winner
stays on there's six teams from six
London boroughs and there's one prize
there's a lot of people that come from
different countries more time than not
they share the same love and passion for
football footballs let that be slack is
like a language in a way I'm playing
with people like that from different
backgrounds and Manilow solicitors and
stuff and doing all these in this thing
and actually I will not hold you first
in society we've bring in like all the
postcode and all that gang's being
together - forgetting about all the
violence just football there's nothing
just positive things
I was not playing in that tournament
I'll just probably be hanging about with
my friends on the the streets Oh boring
if we don't have nothing to do that's
that's what we do so when things like
that come
we're buzzing any time I drift away from
football I get myself into trouble going
off in my community and growing up in my
areas very easy to get dragged into
silly stuff but it's a gang-related but
I'd get myself into unnecessary trouble
with the police or things that I
shouldn't be doing without football I
don't know where I'd be if it doesn't
that in miniature and a pitch all the
troubles from the world like where would
be y'all having problems at home you
have no money you can't pay the bills
that doesn't matter that's the only
thing that's ever kept me going
that's why passion for football never
like running right my mother
yes football is me
[Music]
[Applause]
people from different parts of London
different races different religions
different cultures they're representing
who they are and is so pure and I think
that's what connected with people and
said you know what I'm gonna support
this thing I wants to put my friend I
want to come down that's why we had such
a great turnout it's so important to do
something and you feel passionate about
regardless of what it is the last time
ISM is hopeful for the street the last
time is just more than Street food it's
more than for whiskey it goes deeper
than that they gave them the platform to
showcase who they are not just the
talent also make them feel good about
who they are as a person
culturally their friends in the area
where they belong to a lot of people
look at these things like the lost and I
think I could really go and do something
productive something positive this
tournament breaks barriers it breaks
boundaries it breaks a lot of things you
know that people are scared of and
so much better than it is now
[Applause]